pursuant to standing order 108.2 and the
motion adopted by the committee on
tuesday february 1st
2022
the committee is commencing its study of
crowdfunding platforms and extremism
financing with us today
from the financial transactions and
reports analysis center of canada
barry mccillup deputy director
intelligence
and annette ryan deputy director
partnership policy
and analysis
up to five minutes will be given for
opening remarks after which we will
proceed with rounds of questions
witnesses may choose to share their time
with other witnesses if they wish
welcome to you and i now invite mr
mckillip to make an opening statement of
up to five minutes
floor is yours sir
thank you mr chair for inviting us to
address the committee today
i would like to briefly
speak about fintrax mandate under the
proceeds of crime
money laundering and terrorist financing
act and the valuable role we play in
helping to protect canadians and
canada's economy
mr chair fintrac's mandate is to
facilitate the detection prevention
and deterrence of money laundering and
the financing of terrorist activities
federal departments and agencies that
play a key role in canada's anti-money
laundering and anti-terrorist financing
regime
fintrac was established as an
administrative financial intelligence
unit and not a law enforcement or
investigative agency we do not have the
authority to freeze or seize funds or
cancel or delay financial transactions
this was done very deliberately by the
parliament of canada to ensure that we
would have access to the information
needed to support the money laundering
and terrorist financing investigations
of canada's police
law enforcement and national security
agencies while protecting the privacy of
canadians
as canada's anti-money laundering and
anti-terrorism financing regulator
fintrac is responsible for ensuring the
compliance of thousands of businesses
with requirements under the act
including financial entities casinos
money service businesses real estate and
others
i will note that crowdfunding sites are
not a regulated business sector under
the act
however when these sites transit with or
through
businesses subject to the proceeds of
crime money laundering and terrorist
financing act and its regulations these
financial transactions would be covered
under the act
as part of their obligations businesses
subject to the act are required to
establish a compliance program
identify clients keep records and report
certain types of financial transactions
to fintrac
including international electronic funds
transfers totaling 10 000 or more in a
24-hour period
large virtual currency transactions
totaling 10 000 or more in a 24-hour
period and suspicious transactions which
have no monetary threshold for reporting
mr chair compliance with the broader
legislative and regulatory obligations
provides important measures for
deterring criminals and terrorists from
operating within canada's legitimate
economy
compliance with the legislation ensures
that fintrac receives the information
that we need
to generate financial intelligence
enforcement and national security
agencies to act upon
the reports that we receive from
canadian businesses are analyzed and
assessed and when we have reasonable
grounds to suspect that financial
intelligence would be relevant to
investigating or prosecuting a money
laundering offense or a terrorist
activity financing offense fintrac
generates a financial intelligence
disclosure for canada's police law
enforcement and national security
agencies
under subsection 55 1 of the proceeds of
crime money laundering and terrorist
financing act fintrac is expressly
prohibited from discussing any
information that we receive
or any financial intelligence that we
disclose to canada's police law
enforcement and national security
agencies
what i can say however is that our
financial intelligence is valued by
those agencies many of whom have told us
that they will not start a major project
level investigation without seeking out
our financial intelligence
last year we provided more than two
thousand disclosures of actionable
financial intelligence in support of
investigations related to money
laundering terrorist financing and
threats to the security of canada since
becoming operational in 2001 the center
has provided more than 22 000 financial
intelligence disclosures to canada's
police law enforcement national security
agencies as well as our international
partners
our disclosures include financial
information on an individual or a
network of individuals or entities
suspected to be involved in money
laundering or the financing of terrorist
activities
they can make links between individuals
and businesses that have not been
identified in an investigation and can
help investigators refine the scope of
their cases or shift their sites to
different targets
our financial intelligence is often used
by law enforcement agencies to put
together affidavits to obtain search
warrants and production orders
our financial intelligence can also be
used to identify proceeds of crime and
advance the government's knowledge of
the financial dimensions of certain
crimes and threats including organized
crime and terrorism
last year our financial intelligence
contributed to 376
major resource intensive investigations
and many hundreds of other individual
investigations at the municipal
provincial
federal levels across the country as
well as international investigations
thank you very much unless you have
something that you think is
indispensable and you got 10 seconds
no sir
it will be my pleasure to answer the
questions of the committee
opportunities thank you
and now we begin a round of questions
and to lead off i would invite mr lloyd
to use his six minutes sir the floor is
yours
thank you mr sharon i want to thank the
witness uh for attending um i wanted to
ask the witness is there a
objective
threshold
that you employ
to determine you know when something is
money laundering
and when something is a terrorist
activity my concern is you know the word
terrorist terrorism you know can be
thrown around somewhat carelessly
and i just want to know like what is
your objective standard for what does
constitute those activities thank you
thank you for the question mr chair we
use when we
arrive at our threshold to suspect that
a certain transaction would be relevant
to a money laundering or terrorist
activity financing investigation we have
a number of indicators that we have
developed over the years based on our
intelligence
we've also built on indicators that
are published and are in existence
through the fatf which is the financial
action task force as well as egmont
which is a group of financial
intelligence units internationally we
also have indicators that we have
developed with our domestic and
international partners related to money
laundering as most of you likely know
money laundering is the result and the
use of proceeds of crime so typically a
crime is committed and we would see
often transactions that are linked to
predator predicate of crimes similar to
human trafficking for trafficking for
example or drug trafficking or child
sexual exploitation material on the
internet the purchase of that the
commission of those predicate crimes and
then the movement of money tends to be
the lead and the uh indicator for money
laundering so we do have a number of
indicators and we identify those
indicators uh when we do disclosures to
assist law enforcement and understanding
why we're giving them the intelligence
that we are providing them
and what about for uh terrorism mr
mckillop
for terror thank you sir for terrorist
financing as well we have a number of
indicators that we have developed we
have also shared some of those and we
have shared those indicators with our
reporting entities as well and the
indicators assist both on the money
laundering and the terrorist activity
financing side they assist our
reporting entities and identifying the
transactions that may be associated with
those so they are specific actionable
intelligence indicators that can be used
to identify suspicious transactions
thank you um you know i'm sure like
there's there's a role for legislators
you know in a in a sort of creating a
framework uh as you said based on the
things that the criteria that you use
but do you think it's appropriate you
know for politicians to uh you know call
on finn track to uh investigate uh uh
groups uh as they come up like is that
something that that you guys have a
mandate to do and that you think would
be appropriate to do or or do you think
that following your own mandates and
guidelines is the best way to uh to
conduct your activities
thank you very much for the question
um our mandate is and we were set up
very very specifically not to be an
investigative unit and it's very
important to understand that the the
reports that we receive from our
reporting entity under the pcml tfa
are warrantless reports that we receive
for example the threshold reports of ten
thousand dollars in or out of canada or
anything above 10 000 for example the
vast majority of those that we receive
are on legitimate canadians doing
legitimate business or legitimate
organizations sending money
for business purposes and we have a role
in protecting the privacy of that we are
not an investigative agency otherwise we
would not be able to receive the reports
that we receive
because we provide the intelligence to
law enforcement law enforcement will
then use that as part of their
investigation to develop and obtain the
evidence that they need to go forward in
court
we are also set up as an independent
agency an arm's length agency from the
government it is part of the financial
action task force requirements for an
fiu to be independent of government to
not take direction
such as suggested to investigate
specific individuals or specific groups
we have our mandate we know what we we
need to do uh our reporting entities are
very strong partners and and their due
diligence that they
provide on a daily basis to monitor
these transactions and to work with us
to monitor the right transactions have
proven to be extremely successful the
regime is set up with 13 different
departments and agencies each of which
has a specific mandate each of which
work together
in order to enhance and to strengthen
the regime in canada and to ensure that
we have what we need to have in order to
combat money laundering and terrorist
activity financing
thank you mr mckillop i only have a
minute left but would you say like if at
some future date a government attempted
to change your mandate so that uh
government could uh utilize the
information uh that you gather would
that in your opinion it seems that this
is what your testimony is saying would
that basically make uh your organization
ineffective at being able to do its job
and uh would you consider that to be an
ethical ethical change if that were to
be proposed
thank you for the question
i think it would be not
my personal view per se but i think
there would be uh certainly when we were
set up we were set up um looking at the
constitution and what would be
constitutionally acceptable in terms of
transactions being provided to fintrac
and the reason that we can get those
transactions we do not blindly provide
these transactions to law enforcement we
have to meet our own threshold in terms
of suspecting that it may be relevant to
money laundering or terrorist activity
financing in order to pass that along as
an intelligence disclosure to our
partners so
i i believe it's good
that's good thank you very much
i appreciate
everybody's respect of the clock
i now would invite ms demoff uh she has
six minutes for questions and
conversation and the floor is yours mr
buff
thank you so much chair and mr mckillop
and ms ryan i want to thank you for
coming on such short notice and for the
good work that you do
at fintrac um my first question is i'm
wondering how crowdfunding is captured
under the your regime at fintrac
thank you for the question
crowdfunding itself
and the crowdfunding platforms
themselves are not in fact reporting
entities to uh fintrack so they are not
captured within the regime
uh there was mentioned earlier about the
the payment processors that in fact
process the payments
so um
something like stripe or paypal when
they are doing msb type activities and
some of these payment processors do have
uh msb money service business activities
that they uh participate in when they do
that they are subject to our
legislation and they're subject to uh
being
registered as a money service business
and therefore subject to the compliance
program within uh the pcml tfa
crowdfunding however is not okay great
thank you and then
when you're dealing with entities like
gofundme or gibson go or any actually
any uh
anyone who's accepting money that's in
another country
whether it's united states or other
countries how
do you have information sharing and how
does that work with other countries
because obviously you're not monitoring
financial transactions
you're only monitoring financial
transactions in canada right
well to clarify thank you um we don't
actually monitor the transactions it's
very important it's our reporting
entities we monitor the transactions uh
and crowdfunding platforms themselves
are not covered in uh in the us for
example under fincen crowdfunding
platforms are not covered however
anybody that's donating to
a gofundme page for example they would
donate through a payment processor which
means they would identify themselves
they would need a credit card they would
need to fill in their personal
information so that the
uh donation itself may be validated that
the funds exist and then the funds would
be transferred to gofundme when gofundme
is dispersing the money to the
particular cause
if they are using a canadian bank
account that disbursement will go
through the canadian bank account if
our
canadian bank for example
deemed that disbursement to be
suspicious or relevant to money
laundering or terrorist financing or imv
activity
they would in fact report suspicious
transactions to us
so it's
we don't monitor what gofundme may have
but when the disbursement is made the
disbursement is made through
a canadian bank in the case of canadian
donation pages that have been
established and when a donation page is
established the organizer must also of
that page must also identify themselves
the purpose for the cause the purpose
and the purpose and the way in which the
funding would be dispersed once it's
the the part though is there information
sharing between
uh the united states and canada the or
so your equivalent in the united states
do you have information sharing between
um
in fact uh thank you very much for the
question we do in fact have 103 uh or
mous with internet financial
intelligence units so if fincen were to
receive a sar which is a suspicious
activity report which is the equivalency
or
report um and there's always
possibilities for voluntary information
records or voluntary submissions of
suspicion to fincen or to fintrac
would in fact in fincen would
share that intelligence with us we would
then
seek permission to further share that
information if it met our threshold to
our law enforcement or national security
agencies depending on on the event and
in fact we have done they are our
largest vincent is our largest partner
for the sharing of financial
intelligence back and forth either
spontaneously or as a result of a
request for information so it can be
done both ways thank you um
probably is my last question i'll see
how much time
do you
need to be able to do meaningful
compliance i'm not trying to to play
good work that you do um but you know it
i'm sure it gets busier for you and more
complicated and people get uh
there's a lot of nuances in the work
that you do so i'm just wondering if you
have the resources that you that you
need or if you could do with more thank
you very much for the question uh as a
civil servant i think anybody would
always say oh just give us more uh but i
think the key really to effective
compliance is the partnerships that we
have developed with our reporting
entities our reported entities really do
take their role seriously they see
themselves and they are the front line
of money laundry and terrorist financing
in canada they are the ones that we rely
on and the police rely on
in terms of investigations and the use
of financial intelligence
we have adopted we continue to modernize
our compliance program we continue to
look at a risk-based approach in terms
of compliance and our approach to
compliance so that we spend and we
and use our resources
to the most and the best effect that we
can to address the highest risk areas
and to
ensure the compliance with those risk
areas and a lot of the compliance also
goes to
the education that's that's provided
either through our strategic
intelligence our significant outreach
our significant training
because the better the reporting
entities are at understanding what the
indicators are and how to report the
better reports we get
thank you very much thank you
ms michaud it's your turn you have
six minutes and the floor is yours
thank you mr chair
thank you
for your statement
mr mckillip you were saying in your
opening remarks
that the social funding side such as go
fund me are not among the regulated
sectors according
to the um money laundering act and the
funding of terrorist activity act and
this was implemented in the
2000s gofundme for example
was created in 2010.
do you think that the current state of
law is not adapted to the new reality of
the internet and the virtual reality
that we're faced with and that
legislative changes are required to make
sure that uh
social fun
financing um
businesses such as gofundme be subject
to the act
answer thank you
inaudible
we're always
looking at what we can do to improve
improve are there other sectors that
should be covered or not covered but
when you think about this it's really a
balance that needs to be struck between
the desire to have the most amount of
intel possible
of course the deputy director of
intelligence i would like to have as
much information as possible but there's
a balance that needs to be struck
between what is reported to ventrac and
the private lives and the respect of
individuals privacy and the use of their
financing funding etc so there's always
a balance that needs to be struck so
we're always
looking at sectors that could improve
our current regime
i don't necessarily think that we can
add sectors
because they're being used in a certain
way it depends it depends if it's a
sector that's at risk for terrorist
activities or money laundering and
what will happen if they become
entities like this
pages such as gofundme for example
are set up in the us not in canada
and they're not subject to
our
act
and vice versa so
we
it doesn't mean that we shouldn't do the
necessary study to see if there is a way
to improve our own regime and to improve
the coverage or the use of other sources
we did the same thing with
virtual currency
cryptocurrency this was not covered and
now it is and they report to us and we
receive uh reports with regards to
cryptocurrency so we're always trying to
improve our system
thank you you were talking about having
as much intelligence and information as
possible this type of organization is
not necessarily subject to the act we
understand that they themselves have to
be
of goodwill to send you the information
if you're investigating regardless of
the platform or the business if you see
that there's a huge amount of money
that's being gathered in a small amount
of time if you see organizations that
are affiliated to the extreme right
and that can do this does this raise any
red flags do you look at it or if
there's no information sent to you you
don't necessarily look at it how does it
work
answer
well we always look at what's happening
and are reporting entities well
as i was saying
there's an intersection between the
financial system
so
there has to be a bank account used or
there has to be
a bank
used to share the money that is
collected are reporting entities
do a lot of research
in the media they look at the media each
and every day they know who's involved
they know who the organizers are they
know and what's happening in the world
they always check to see
if there are people who are
known known bad actors let us say
if they're involved this is always
looked at and they try to submit the
information to us
and so
there
there's always a link with the financial
system and this is where we receive
reports we will receive reports if
there's a link with
funding of terrorism or money laundering
so right now of course we're looking at
the money that was amassed for
the convoy that's now become a siege
here in ottawa in front of the
parliament so we have this in mind but
looking at other files that you've
worked with is the anonymous character
of donations something that well
according to you does this open the door
to criminal activity or to money
laundering when you see all these
anonymous donations that are being made
thank you for the question
the question of anonymity well this is a
gray zone because the donations are not
really anonymous to make a donation
people have to use a credit card they
have to
um go through a system such as stripe
for example
in order to
send money to the cause so it's not
really anonymous what we see publicly
is anonymous we don't see the name of
the donor it appears as anonymous it's
as if
if
if during our funding campaign i was to
make a donation and i was asked well
do you want your name to appear if i say
no it's going to say
anonymous but it's not really anonymous
and the
the company such as stripe or gofundme
they know exactly who this is gofundme
decided to close the page and to refund
the donors this leads me to believe that
they do have all the necessary
information on the credit cards and the
individuals allowing for refunds so
donations are not truly
fascinating point and uh maybe a good
one to end this particular exchange
uh now we'll go to mr mcgregor
who will have six minutes uh in uh
questions and the floor is now yours mr
mcgregor take it away
thank you so much chair um
you know the special bulletin that
fintrac produced on imve uh stated that
imve threat actors have raised funds
through crowdfunding and through
accepting donations and you know our
canadian security intelligence service
has divided it roughly into
rough four categories that's xenophobic
violence anti-authoritarian violence
gender driven
and other grievance-driven violence and
of course our criminal code has a
definition of terrorism um which is you
know an act committed in whole or in
part for a political religious or
ideological purpose objective or cause
with the intention of intimidating the
public
and the activities recognized as
criminal within this context they can
include
significant property damage and
interference or disruption of essential
services facilities or systems which i
think any casual observer looking at
ottawa right now uh
could probably make make a link i guess
what i'm trying to to
dig into here is the relationship
between the payment service providers
like for example stripe and paypal the
crowdfunding organization
and then the financial entity
to which the
funds are eventually distributed to
um
like for example do the
payment service providers do they have
information when they're receiving uh
donations do they understand
or do
like where why the donations are coming
in do they understand for what purpose
they're coming in does the crowdfunding
site have that link with the crowd with
the service provider
that's um a little outside of my lane
but thank you very much for the question
i'm not an expert on the service
provision or the service provider or
gofundme but my understanding is that
the page is set up for a particular
cause
people use when they want to donate
it's a behind-the-scenes
uh
service that's provided
so stripe for example would have the
identity of the person that is making
the donation they would have their
credit card they would have their own
all their identification in order to
validate that the funds exist and
transfer to the particular page so they
would know that it's going to a
particular page
my understanding as well is that both
stripe and you know paypal
go fund me give sen go they all have
terms of service which they clearly
identify that they will not support
anything that is related to money
laundering criminal activity
or
terrorist financing
many of these i would assume given that
they're they exist in
stripe for example in a million
different
companies
and hundreds of countries
that they do as well have a their own
internal compliance program their own
internal media watch program that they
are
um very uh socially responsible when it
comes to identifying uh where that money
may be going and would i would think
not
want to process money that we're going
to a cause that was identified as uh
an illegal cause for example but yeah
like that that was sort of that's my
question because you know the the
financial service company like paypal
they are required to report to you
but would they understand uh or would
they be able to generate their own
intelligence that we know this money was
going to a particular crowdfunding site
for this cause like what they would be
able to generate that intelligence if
they thought it was suspicious
they would and
strike
could as uh registered msps they would
and could submit reports to us with
respect to that
miss ryan did you have something to add
yeah i'd like to i'd like to just point
out that the special bulletin that you
refer to was produced explicitly by
fintrac to inform the reporting entities
what to look for
and we work closely as uh as my
colleague barry said with international
partners to keep track of emerging
trends so that we can feed that back to
our private sector partners so that you
know they know what to look for
and you know i would say that uh the
fact that we're able to follow those
trends and then feed them back uh two
partners that you see in the report
shows that you know there are threads um
essentially line of sight to the
crowdfunding
sector through the psb's that are
reporting to us through the msbs that do
report to us based on their ability to
follow the transactions back to
individuals we can then uh you know look
at the relevant patterns and
have a sense of you know what's uh
suspicious what raises to the level that
uh our colleagues on the operational
side can share with competent
authorities and in that way that's how
the system remains fresh as to you know
what is suspicious as uh
illicit activity evolves through time
and just quickly i've only got 45
seconds just you know when when you are
producing actionable intelligence
for law enforcement i i know you're not
an investigative agency
but you you know you do
formulate a lot of your opinions based
on the reports you receive i mean but
but do you also like passively receive
information from other sources i mean
you you're you see the news every day
you're aware of what's going on does
that how how
much does that figure in your reporting
to uh intelligence agencies
in 10 seconds i'm afraid
thank you mr chair yes we do open source
intelligence in support of the
disclosures that we
we produce and we will provide that with
the disclosures if it's relevant
appreciate it thank you thank you
colleagues i'm looking at the clock we
have a hard stop at the top of the hour
we have 15 minutes left and
coincidentally and happily
that means that i could call on a
representative from each party and they
can take their full allotment of time
and we should end within a minute
so
mr van popta you're first you have five
minutes please proceed
good thank you very much and thank you
mr mckillip and ms ryan for being here
uh and informing us on the important
work that you do
uh i just
i want uh some clarification maybe from
mr mckillop
and that is that uh a uh if my
understanding of your
testimony is correct uh
a crowdfunding platform would is is not
regulated by by fintrac so they would
never make the report but it is the
money service businesses
that are feeding money to the
crowdfunding
platform or a bank receiving
the money from the crowdfunding platform
that are
regulated to report suspicious
transactions is my understanding correct
that is correct sir okay good so thank
you so
uh
so um
a money service business such as stripe
or paypal
or visa or mastercard or whoever it
might be
um
are there clear guidelines
as to
what they have to look for for
uh terrorism type funding or
or money laundering what do they look
for
thank you sir for the question they they
do have clear guidelines the guidelines
uh are available and they're on our
website we provide guidelines we
identify as well uh different reasons
perhaps for submitting strs and we
provide those guidelines we also provide
a number of very specific indicators
that would help them in their
transaction monitoring for example we
have five very very successful
public-private partnerships dealing with
human trafficking fentanyl trafficking
romance scams underground banking
child sexual exploitation material on
the internet these ppps as we call them
we have set out with our reporting
entities and we provide very actionable
indicators that they can plug into their
own systems to create the algorithms to
assist them in identifying suspicious
transactions that may be related to
those types of predicate crimes we've
also provided them with terrorist
financing indicators imve indicators as
my colleagues
to assist them in identifying those
types of transactions as you know it's
often not simply one transaction but
often a pattern of transactions that's
required to look at and we assist them
in providing them as many
clear indicators guidance outreach
training in order to
enhance that and i think that we've the
success that we've seen
is i think demonstrable through the
increase in our suspicious transaction
reports that we've received year over
year
as well as the
uh increase in the number of voluntary
information records that we've received
from the police seeking our
assistance in their investigations as
those increase
we've been able to increase our
disclosures and it clearly shows that
not only are the reporting entities
doing their job really really well in
providing us those reports but the
police
and our law enforcement national
security
uh agencies both in canada and
internationally
significantly appreciate our disclosures
and are coming in to get them as often
as they possibly can to assist in their
investigations
good thank you
ms ryan i think your hand is up
it is sir i'd like to draw your
attention to several international
documents that our reporting entities
would also consult which canada works
quite closely to produce these include
in july of 2019 terrorist financing risk
assessment guidance in july of 2021
ethnically or racially motivated
terrorism financing and as well uh
specific documents such as the financial
action task force's best practices on
combating the abuse of not-for-profit
organizations so we do
work quite closely on a very rich and
detailed
guidance that is based
so i think you've gone on to mute
okay good
okay okay thank you um
so there's an increase in
sars suspicious activity reporting so is
that an indication of more
more suspicious transactions happening
or the reporting
entities just getting better at
understanding
what to look for
thank you for the question and you're
right it is suspicious transaction
reporting in canada the sars are in the
u.s
uh i believe it's a combination of both
it's not that we have uh you know an ex
explosion of criminality necessarily
i
am better at identifying predicate
crimes associated to money laundering
and or terrorist financing and it's the
quality of those reports
us to do our job to meet our threshold
and to provide actionable intelligence
to our law enforcement national security
agencies both in canada as well as
internationally as i mentioned we do
have a hundred and
nine or 110
uh
mou's with international fius that we
can share information with
thank you very much
and now i'll turn the floor over to mr
newer mohammed sir you have five minutes
to question
go ahead
yeah thanks very much uh mr chair and uh
thank you mr mckillip and ms ryan for
joining us uh mr mckillop i guess a
question for you to start with you know
we've seen over the course of the last
little while a lot of interest from the
united states in the funding situation
related to uh related to gofundme and
and the block in the the blockade of
ottawa you've seen some fairly unsavory
characters in the u.s like marjory
taylor green weighing in on this how
concerned should canadians be
about foreign funding or foreign funds
coming in to canada
and spurring on ideologically motivated
violent extremism
thank you for the question mr chair
the money
what's happening in ottawa has not been
um to my knowledge identified as
ideologically motivated violent
extremists
we
might come into canada to support
ideologically motivated violent
extremism and the united states would be
extremely concerned about money leaving
the states or funding
such extremist viewers such extremist
actions
our partners in fincen are quite alive
to this we share a lot of intelligence
back and forth with respect to imves
with respect to
traveling people that want to leave the
country
to participate in uh terrorist
activities for example
so we do
and we work with our egmont and our five
eyes partners very closely with respect
to that so any funding that would be
linked to imve
is
of extreme concern and importance to us
and we would
disclose that intelligence to our law
enforcement national security partners
so i believe that um
you know the
any action that's taken by those actors
or by sanctioned groups for example a
listed terrorist organization for
example or members that are or people
that are known to be members of those
um organizations both our financial
institutions but also those in the
united states i'm sure
um know who these people are they do
monitor their transactions and they do
report
action added or completed with respect
to them
so one very brief question then do you
have any concerns or have there been any
flags raised thus far
around potential sources of funding for
what has been happening in ottawa
thank you for the question no the
sources of funding that we've seen um
today we have not seen a spike and as
you know i can't speak to specific
reporting or uh reporting on any
individuals or organizations but we have
not seen a spike in suspicious
transaction reporting for example
related to this
great thank you i'm going to give the
rest of my time to mr zabari whatever
time i have left
thank you uh mr muhammad and um thank
you to witnesses for being here
i just want to ask um zoom out a bit and
ask a question related to individuals
who
might find that their transactions are
um
are
frozen um international transactions and
these are law-abiding citizens canadians
who
have no problems at all with the law
um and our upright citizens
do they have any recourse um when when
let's say that they're sending money to
a family member is there any recourse
for them to untangle themselves and they
believe it's it's a false positive and
that's why their money has been
intercepted can you can you inform us
about that
thank you sir for the question
that would not be certainly a role that
fintrac plays as i mentioned we can
either investigate nor can we seize nor
can we freeze funds nor do we ask any
financial institution to delay a
financial transaction
the recourse would be with their own
financial institution if in fact their
funds were put on hold or were frozen we
have seen that happen
it's happened in
uh
instances where we see this through some
of the suspicious transaction reporting
where the narrative
the bank for example may tell us that
the the funds were put on hold until
such time as their request for further
information was completed and fulfilled
by the individual and then it's really
up to the banks and the other financial
institutions who have their own
and they determine their own level of
risk that they're willing to to
manage with respect to the accounts and
the accounts of their their clients so
this would really be something that the
individual would have to take up with
their own bank
and to determine what the
risk was that was identified by the bank
and how that may be mitigated thank you
thank you and and we have about 40
seconds um and related to that um do you
provide guidelines along those um along
those questions clarity for banks and
other institutions around that
no our guidelines are more along the
lines of what they need to report to us
and how to report not how to manage
their own
risk and risk determination nor how they
manage the accounts of their clients
thank you very much thank you very much
and now i'll turn to ms michaud miss
micho you have two and a half
minutes you mr chair
you mentioned this that your mandate is
to fight against money laundering and
the funding of terrorist activities
when there are social funding platforms
or businesses that are not subject to
the
act
on the proceeds of crime or the funding
of terrorist activities do you think
that this
poses problems in canada's ability to
detect and prevent not only money
laundering
and the funding of terrorist activities
but also foreign interference given that
some platforms or businesses can be
based in other countries and and money
can come from foreign countries as well
thank you for the question
as i was saying
what we're going through right now is a
unique uh event we've never seen the use
of of
these platforms as being a place
that could be used
to facilitate money laundering or
funding of terrorism there is always a
risk
but
this has not been
traditionally a platform that would have
been used um to these ends there are
many other ways probably easier ways
to try to launder a cache or to
collect money for terrorist activity so
this is a unique event are we going to
learn from this yes
are discussions underway are we going to
continue to discuss with our foreign
partners yes of course as you mentioned
these platforms exist on the internet
they're accessible by everyone
throughout the world
if someone is supporting a cause whether
it be this cause or another cause
could be
helping people who wanted to leave
afghanistan i would imagine that there
were some gofundme
for that people from anywhere in the
world can support this type of cost by
making donations so i would say that i
can't give a percentage but these social
media platforms were useful for
collecting money to help people in need
throughout the world
we really have to find a balance
between what could be imposed
as
as a burden and
the
intelligence that could be received
so now uh for the last slot i will turn
to mr mcgregor you have two and a half
minutes and you will take us within a
minute or two to the top of the clock
floor is yours
thank you so much chair um in april of
last year you know there was a data
breach from the christian crowdfunding
site give sengo um that data breach
revealed that there were millions of
dollars that had been raised by groups
uh banned from raising funds on other
platforms so
um they had been banned
because of episodes of hate speech and
violence that had been used on the
platform some of the biggest
beneficiaries of that had been groups
like the proud boys which are a
designated terrorist entity so we only
learned of this because of a data breach
i'm just wondering um
you know we as policy makers have to
anticipate the new landscape that's
before us
does fintrack have what it needs uh to
to capture this maybe not from
a a site like um gofundme
but for other platforms which are
competing for this space and for those
dollars
are there gaps that we need to plug as
policy makers so that you know these
things can be catched but caught before
they end up being just a data breach
thank you for your question
mr chair i think it's
always good to ask the question and to
do an in-depth study once you're out of
a crisis to determine whether or not
there are policy gaps that could be
could be looked at and what is the best
way to address those
uh from my perspective right now
in the situation that you mentioned i've
read about the data breach as well
the intersection with
the crowdfunding platforms and our
financial institutions
is a must in order to disperse the money
and if the money were going through a
canadian bank for example and directed
to the proud boys they're a listed
terrorist organization that money would
be stopped by the bank and we would also
get the str they cannot if there's a
list of terror or terrorist organization
facilitate the transfer of that money so
it is really the intersection
with our banks and
our banks are well aware of those
organizations and the individuals
associated with those organizations
they know who they are they have their
sanctions list they do their monitoring
and they do do their reporting and they
do it well
so from my perspective we have that
intersection
and raising
is likely not helpful to those
organizations but we would get the
reporting or the the funding would be
stopped by the banks when it comes to
those types of organizations trying to
receive money thank you thank you very
much and i want to on behalf of the
committee
thank the
witnesses for
very important and thoughtful testimony
this morning
it will be very important as we make
through the complexities of these very
important and dynamic issues
colleagues right on time thank you very
much for everybody's cooperation does
the committee agree that the meeting
should be adjourned
then the meeting is adjourned have a
good weekend everybody we'll see you on
tuesday
take care
thanks everybody thanks chair